we are back now at 7 30 here on cbs
mornings and we are diving into the
question of whether american politics
has an age problem let's go through the
numbers president biden already the
oldest sitting president is set to
become the first president to turn 80 in
office by the way that's a feat that
former president trump would match if he
wins another term meanwhile the u.s
senate is also the oldest in history
with an average age of nearly 65
while over in the house nancy pelosi is
the oldest ever speaker at the age of
82. now you might say such is the will
of the voters and that is true however
many americans are also admitting to
doubts and it's raising a delicate
question how old if ever is too old for
national office
if you want a really educated opinion
about our political elders you could do
a lot worse than to start here
behind the wheel of a golf cart at the
villages in florida america's largest
senior community do you support age
limits in politics
we already know what many younger
americans are thinking our country and
our state are being run by a geriatric
oligarchy south carolina's former
congressman joe cunningham for example
has made his opinion
pretty darn clear that's why it's time
to put term limits and age limits on
politicians but surely that kind of talk
would sound ageist to older americans
right do you think our politicians are
too old absolutely you do there is an
age i think when when
a person doesn't have the capabilities
of
of conducting the kind of things you
have in office i feel the same way
really oh yeah
in fact just about every single person
we ran into at the villages supported
age limits i'm almost 80 now i think
somebody 80 doesn't belong
as a leader 70 75 tops get out out of
politics
yes
it's not just in florida either a new
cbs news poll finds 73 percent of all
americans support maximum age limits for
elected officials
with greater support to my surprise
coming from seniors than from younger
adults i don't think i have the
sharpness
and the christmas
and the mentality that i had
even 10 years ago youth used to be a
defining feature of america under wigs
and powdered hair the average founding
father was actually a mere 44. the
question of senility
is sort of an obvious question tal copen
is deputy d.c bureau chief for the
boston globe i and a colleague wrote a
story about senator dianne feinstein
raising this very question published in
april when copen was at the san
francisco chronicle she reported that
four sitting u.s senators including
three democrats believe the 89-year-old
feinstein's memory is rapidly
deteriorating and she may be mentally
unfit to serve the dynamic that was
being described of a senator who was
unable to recall conversations that had
just happened
that raises a real question as to
whether you know the principal is
actually running the office anymore i
was struck by the part of the piece
where you describe some sources as
telling you this in sadness i would say
almost every single conversation yes in
a statement feinstein cited the hard
times she's had adjusting to her
husband's recent death
saying i work as hard as i can to solve
problems for the people of california
but it's not just congress that has
people thinking american politics has an
age problem i am a young
vibrant man former president trump
portrayed himself as the healthiest
chief executive in american history i'm
an extremely stable
genius but with clips like these critics
trying to argue that in fact he's in the
midst of a dangerous decline you had a
right to wonder if there's something
wrong with the workings of the
president's mind and president biden has
faced some of the same criticism from
his political opponents all men and
women created by the goal you know that
you know the thing
these are signs of senility
which is a common thing in elderly
people and even among democrats a recent
poll shows that age is the top concern
among those looking for a different
candidate in 2024. we have a saying in
geriatrics you've seen one 85 year old
you've seen 185 year old they're all
different dr mark lax is chief of
geriatrics at weill cornell medicine in
new york what is it that a voter should
look for legitimately when it comes to
age and performance well that's a good
softball is it not a softball yeah it's
it's not a softball it's uh it's a
hardball yeah so so it's very difficult
for a layperson to do that he explained
that yes it is normal as we age for the
brain to shrink look at the size of
these two brains and yes in general an
older mind is more likely to struggle
with memory we don't expect an 80 year
old to remember like a 40 year old but
many 80 year olds are also sharp as ever
which is why he says political age
limits would be both arbitrary
and wrong you know aging tony brings
something that youth doesn't it's
judgment and experience there's no
replacement for that over a lifetime of
relationships you mentor younger people
i mean if there are no older people in
the legislature
who's going to bring these young people
up back in washington tal copen says
there's already a test that determines
whether any given politician is too old
for office it's the test that happens
on election day the answer is the voters
at the end of the day
the collective power of the american
electorate is the only way to effectuate
change in our government by
flaw or by design that is what it is
it is what it is you could end every
piece that way by the way we also
reached out to the white house for
comment on this and a spokesperson told
us as president biden has said anyone
with questions about his age should just
watch him close quote then listed off a
number of the president's
accomplishments uh that same person
pointed out that the poll we mentioned
showing a concern among democrats over
the president's age also showed that
just three percent of people in that
poll listed mental acuity his sharpness
uh as their
top concern
i like your doctor in the piece i like
your doctor in the piece who said if
you've met one 85 year old that's what
you've met 185 year old i don't think
it's the age so much as it is the person
in their ability i think it should be
focused on what the person can do as
opposed to the age the problem is most
people don't know that it's their time
to go that's right have you ever tried
to take keys away from an older relative
yeah i mean they're clutching them they
have the death grip on it so they don't
unders they don't understand when the
time has gone but but you know again as
you point out in the piece tony the
majority of americans do believe that
there should be some limit on age and
the problem of course is that those
lawmakers who ultimately would have to
crack that legislation are themselves
in their 70s and 80s and so they're not
looking to you know take themselves out
of the job yeah i like the term limits i
i like term limits more than age because
i think after you've been in the job for
x amount of years certainly in politics
i think that it
you need a fresher perspective a newer
point of view i think well
we're going to talk a little bit more
about this and talk at the table there's
more from our poll which i think is
amazing showing that majority of people
supporting age limits we also ask them
what that age limit should be which is
where things get complicated that's
interesting because i'm like term limits
are one thing i'm kind of behind that
but age yeah
i mean listen guys walter cronkite had
to retire at 65. yeah i'm 67 i wouldn't
have this job
and then isn't that sad to think about
yes that is very sad
dodged a bullet in 2022
come